And that's it, job done.
We've taken an entirely
online only site and
made it an offline
first progressive app.
By making it to the end of this course,
you're ready to take on
any offline first project.
Wittr was specifically designed to cover
most of the gnarly edge cases you'll
encounter in the wild.
For example, cache versioning for
big updates like theme changes,
interactive updates to get the user onto
the latest version, dealing with server
rendering by serving a page skeleton,
responsive images, multiple caches,
you even had to master indexedDB,
the most feared API in the platform.
You did it all.
But to spell out exactly what we
achieved, for the very last time,
we dial into America land.
Mike, are you there?
>> I am.
>> Show us where we started and
where we are now?
>> With pleasure.
If the user's on some kind
of non-perfect connection,
they used have to wait for the page
to appear, and imagery took ages.
Now, stuff appears on
the screen instantly.
Lie-fi users used to be left staring
at a white screen forever, but
now they get content instantly.
Offline users used to get
a browser error page.
Now they get content and
a non-disruptive custom error.
This is a huge improvement
in the user experience.
>> If your site works offline first,
users are going to notice that it loads
reliably and fast whatever the network.
They'll have a less frustrating
experience with your site than the rest
of the web, and that's what matters,
the user experience.
And with that, it's goodbye from me.
>> And goodbye from me.
>> We look forward to a web that
works whatever the connection is.